l'équipe de l'heure du monde et à
memphis où l'on commémore aujourd'hui le
50e anniversaire de la mort de martin
luther king
les préparatifs impressionnants sont
presque terminé ici au lorraine motel
transformé depuis en musée national des
droits civiques
pourquoi aux lorraines montel parce que
c'est ici que logeait martin luther king
c'est ici qu'il a trouvé la mort qu'il a
été abattu sur le balcon devant sa
chambre
la 306 par un tireur qui était planquée
dans une maison de chambres de l'autre
côté de la rue martin luther king était
à memphis pour appuyer les hiboux heures
en grève
la ville et c'est ici à l'église
claiborne au centre ville de memphis que
ces éboueurs en grève se donner rendez
vous chaque jour depuis le déclenchement
de leur grève en février pour
entreprendre une marche pacifique vers
l'hôtel de ville se faire entendre des
élus et cinquante ans plus tard la ville
de memphis leur rend hommage reconnaît
la justesse de leur combat et de leurs
demandes
on inaugure cette semaine tout à côté de
l'église la place à mvan je suis un
homme c'était le slogan des éboueurs en
grève les éboueurs demandé à la ville
d'être traités comme des hommes et non
pas comme des enfants demandé à la ville
de seysses et ce regard condescendant et
vous le voyez on en est aux derniers
préparatifs
ce parc invite au recueillement
on nous propose de revivre le conflit de
travail le long d'un parcours ponctué de
toutes les dates importantes de ce
conflit de travail du 1er février 1968
lorsque deux éboueurs avaient trouvé la
mort dans un compacteur à déchets
défectueux dans lequel il s'était
réfugié pour s'abriter de la pluie
le 12 février lorsque 1300 travailleurs
de la ville avait déclenché la grève le
23 février lorsque les autorités avaient
employé la force pour réprimer les
manifestants ce qui nous amène au 18
mars lorsque martin luther king vient
s'adresser aux travailleurs en grève ils
appuient leur demander leur dis marché à
ma suite marché à ma suite je serai là
pour vous ce qu'il viendra faire le
jeudi 28 mars
malheureusement la marche dégénère
c'est l'émeute c'est la répression
martin luther king vient de vivre tout
le contraire de ce qu'ils souhaitaient
la résistance non violente
une semaine plus tard martin luther king
revient à memphis il a bon espoir de
pouvoir tenir une marche pacifique
malheureusement le 4 avril il sera
assassiné même fils lui rend hommage
aujourd'hui et rend hommage à ces
travailleurs en grève dont tous les noms
ont été inscrits au centre de ce parc